Now that we've described
the instantaneous velocity
of an object, we'd
now like to describe
what it's acceleration is.
Philosophy and acceleration
are complicated things.
One of the reasons
why acceleration
is such an abstract
quantity is for example,
if I take this marker
that's in my hand
and I throw it up in
the air and I catch it,
you can see with
your eye, velocity.
You can see the speed.
You have a sense for it.
You can see it
change its direction.
So velocity is something
that as a human being,
with our eye as a mechanism for
determining motion-- velocity
is a very basic concept.
But acceleration is a
much harder concept.
For instance, when I
take that same object
and I drop that--
as it falls down,
its velocity is increasing.
And so we say it
has an acceleration,
but is that acceleration
a function of time?
Or is it constant in time?
Is it varying in time?
Is it a polynomial?
Is it a constant?
Those are much harder to see.
Again, let's drop this object.
So when I drop that object
and I catch it down here,
our eye does not tell
us intuitively anything
about the mathematical
nature of that acceleration.
And that's why acceleration is
a much more abstract quantity.
In fact, a great question
is the following.
When I throw this object
up in the air-- let's
focus at its highest point.
So I throw it in the
air and it comes down.
When the object was
at its highest point,
was its velocity zero?
Was its acceleration
zero or non-zero?
A hint to this question
is in Newton's second law,
F equals ma.
If there is a force
acting on this object,
there must be an acceleration.
And that forces the
gravitational force.
And when this object was
at the top of its motion
I didn't turn the earth off.
So there is still a
gravitational force.
And so for an object in
free fall-- now free fall
just as under the-- which
means under the influence
of the gravitational force.
We can conclude from
Newton's second law
that the gravitational
force, ma--
so this gravitational
force is non-zero.
And so therefore, the
acceleration is also non-zero.
So once again, as I
throw this object up
in the air nobody turned gravity
off, we're not in empty space,
and near the
surface of the Earth
the gravitational
force is not zero.
The acceleration is not zero.
So throughout this motion
this object is accelerating.
I choose this example to
show you that acceleration
is a very abstract concept.
And now our goal
is to figure out
how to mathematically
define acceleration
in terms of our velocity.